Welcome to homework one. We're going to be breaking some code today.
What you need to do for this homework is break a few incorrect implementations
of the fixed-size queue we've been working with earlier in the unit.
Let's go ahead and take a look at what the queue is supposed to do first.
The queue class is just a fixed-size queue of integers and the constructor down here
is supposed to take a single integer parameter greater than 0.
That is the maximum number of elements that the queue can hold at a time,
and there are four methods that we're going to need to concern ourselves with,
and these method calls are all you're going to have access to during this.
The empty call should return true if and only if the queue
currently holds no elements and false, otherwise.
The full method should do the exact opposite.
It should return true if and only if the queue cannot hold anymore elements--
it's completely full and false, otherwise.
You would call it like this or like this or the empty and full methods, respectively.
The enqueue is the only one that takes a parameter. It takes an integer to put into the queue.
It returns true if it's successfully does so and it returns false, otherwise,
which would only happen or should only happen if the queue is full.
The dequeue method does not take any parameters or removes an integer from the queue and returns it.
If it doesn't, if it fails to return anything, which should only happen
if the queue is empty, then it returns none.
As an example if this code where we first create a queue of size 1, then we check if it's empty,
which it should be immediately since we haven't done anything with it so it's empty,
should be true then we try to enqueue the number of 10 which also should succeed since
it should be able to hold one more element so succeeded should be true then we check if it's full
which should also be true because we just enqueued one element we can only
hold one element so it's full should be through then we dequeue that element and
should return 10 the value, so value should be 10 in here to give an idea of what we
should expect from the queue implementation.
Now the five queues that you're going to test for are going to have bugs here and there in them,
so they're not going to behave exactly like this.
I very much recommend reading over this specification carefully before you start testing.
Now to test the five queues you're going to do exactly what you do here.
You would instantiate queue and call these four methods in sum fashion and then
using assert statements, you would try to break this code and draw in it assertion error.
On the back end, we'll have a test harness that runs your code against all of the buggy queue
implementations and will return the incorrect output if you manage to find it and when you
run submit bin on your code it will tell you how many of the buggy queue implementations
you have manage to successfully catch.
As an example of what your test code should do if we run my implementation against the buggy code
then we see that we get in assertion error here.
So your code should run assertion errors for all of the buggy code.
We'll have a test harness that will run your code against all five of the incorrect implementations
and when you submit your code we'll tell you how many of the implementations
you've managed to successfully catch and your goal is to catch all five.
It took me, I think 22 lines to catch all the bugs--so let's see if you can beat me.